[Musique]
il y a eu un terrible accident
j'ai eu la chance d'être en sortir
non d'abord parce qu'on s'est dit
fille je crois pas c'est une fille
pardon j'avais jamais vu de tes filles
avant
[Musique]
yarn sais pas car nous si on appelle ça
le bruit tous les hommes de cette
planète l'entendent
toutes les pensées qu'on enquête sont
visibles ou sont tout les sens
à
elles sont mortes de mauvais bonds et
son bruit ça fait bizarre de voir tes
pensées et c'est bizarre pour moi ne pas
voir ce que tu as en tête
j'ignore si tu déteste mon chien ou si
tu as envie de me frapper avec une
pierre pendant jet d'eau tourner ton
chien je les adore il est plus fort
qu'une de l'époque c'était ma tension
avec ton bruyère pas un serpent
si la trappe il te tuerons
le protéger cette fille il faut goûter
je vais te protéger quand on sait que
protéger
avec le pouvoir que l' on ne sait pas de
quoi il est capable
le fond cette fille à conclure à vienne
combien vous débarquiez 102 ans des
milliers
[Musique]
allez je suis de derrick soir nomme pour
titre j'essaie je toucherai pas toi à
toi
[Musique]
je veux pas dire que ce qui vous est
arrivé n'était pas traumatisant atterrir
ont atterri au milieu de nulle part
complètement coupée de vie qu'on avait
laissé derrière ce qui nous amène à la
question qui nous intéresse tous ce
qu'est ce qu'elle avait elle aussi
grandiose et si merveilleux les [ __ ]
de vie qu'on a fait
[Musique]
j'ai l'impression que où que j'aille on
attend de moi que je réponde précisément
à toutes les attentes
[Musique]
à l'arrêt
on est coincés ici on est au 21ème
siècle les filles ils vont nous trouver
ma vie et tout là-bas à des millions de
kelowna prophétie d'accord c'est vrai il
ya eu des traumatismes et pour une
adolescente vivant dans notre amérique
si c'était ça le véritable enfer
on peut dire que la mort rôde au dessus
global
[Musique]
pourtant la seule chose qu'ils sont
m'intéressait c'est l'amour
c'est parce qu'il nous effraie tous on a
tous peur depuis être
le triangle des bermudes oui
l'impression que quelque chose clochait
public
m
quel genre de personnes voient une il
remplit deux filles perdues et dans
votre pâte renfort votre fille a
commencé la remontée d'un
le précipice
parfois je me sens coupable d'avoir dû
mentir à notre fille vous avez fait ça
pour la sauver
ton
[Musique]
vous avez cette occasion unique d'être
le premier d'entre nous à entrer dans le
prochain siècle
personne au monde ne peut approcher un
tel niveau de réalisme à 12 heures c'est
incroyable
je suis pas compenser tout ce concept
c'est l'avenir sa vie
mais robot feront toutes les choses que
vous leur demanderez bonjour sophy
ne laissez pas ce robot évoluer trop
émotionnellement et trop rapidement sa
taille à stresser et james pourquoi vous
me demandez ça je peux peut-être vous
aider
je vous aime bien et si vous le traitez
comme une personne
il pourrait se comporter comme tel
qu'est ce qui vous fait sourire voir que
vous êtes heureuse s'il devait y avoir
un problème quelconque henry est
programmé pour revenir à sa cabine de
réglages et se réinitialiser quel genre
de problèmes peuvent survenir des
problèmes d'ordre secondaire
mais brille
où suis-je ce qui est en train de rêver
je rêvais que j'étais un humain
visiblement il répond à tout ce que tu
leur courage à mr vous ressentez le
désir sans seul voulez vous que je
puisse le ressentir
parce que ça fait de vous une personne
fermé les yeux alors arrête
immédiatement ce que tu fais avant qu'il
soit complètement détraqué c'est
peut-être vous qui devriez changer
[Musique]
je vais résoudre ça tout de suite
le tout de suite dans votre cabine de
réglages
pas question je n'irai pas
quel est votre projet j'ai interrogé 3
schizophrène qui prétendent être jésus
joseph kessel clyde benson les ongs à
bord je voulais mettre tous les trois
dans la même pièce et étudier leur
comportement
que pourrait-il se produire si nous
tenons ces réunions c'est parce qu'il ne
peut y avoir qu'un seul jésus un seul et
unique tube de prétendus qui s'écaille
adressez vous à moi comme à votre
seigneur votre dieu vous ne pouvez pas
franchir les limites imposées par le
protocole clinique
cette expérience est très importante et
courage c'est une approche respectueuse
vote électrochoc ni de médication la
sécurité des patients et ma
responsabilité
un homme sérieux à force d'endurer fini
par se briser et il n'avait pas autorisé
vous m'avez sauvé de l'électrocution
vous avez ma gratitude infinie
pourquoi voulez vous travailler avec des
schizophrènes par admin parce qu'ils
sont très seuls
votre travail est novateur et en cheveux
avant de décider si les bénéfices
possibles justifie les risques encourus
regardez il commence sans qu'on leur
dise
[Musique]
je mets fin à l'expérience avez vous
peur de moi pouces est l'homme le plus
puissant de cette institution
l'année un cran mais il ya des limites à
ne pas franchir
serait en mesure de fournir à ses hommes
les moyens de découvrir qui
[Musique]
faites bien attention
dans le barrio
quand le ciel devient noir les choses
tournent mal
quand on était enfant pour nous raconter
la légende à chaque fois que la tension
monte dans le quartier on entendait le
bruit et sans moteur approcher les
gangsters se sont tournés vers dieu
tellement ils craignaient ce diable
c'était qui elle crie canon
le cartel a tué plusieurs officiers de
police il a l'intention de faire faute
et son drapeau sur la californie j'ai
jamais vu ça c'est un champ de bataille
il savait que ça allait arriver que quoi
allait arriver
la révolution bingo
reste avec moi à telle date avec moi
pour être honnête avec toi je suis perdu
je sais plus quoi faire
j'ai toujours essayé de faire le bien
aujourd'hui je de rendre la justice
c'est ça que je veux devenir c'est le
seul moyen de protéger ma ville
c'est dur dans tes yeux
qu'est ce que tu vois
la rage
connaître son ennemi
c'est moi le roi de cette ville
guerre est déclarée 24 heures avant
qu'ils lui en cela son avenir j'ai ma
famille
moi je ne suis ni bons ni juste moi je
triompherait par le sang
chikane celui qui sème la mort dans
quartier